and welcome to Hannity and happy New
Year and happy election year 2024 Now
The Exodus out of big States like New
Jersey California Illinois New York it
continues in fact tonight we are now
broadcasting from my new home the great
free state of Florida like so many
Americans I left New York for good and
am now in the state with let's see
warmer weather Law and Order better
education more freedom uh better quality
of life and guess what no state income
tax now here is my prediction this Mass
migration out of Deep Blue States like
the ones I just me mentioned that will
continue unless and until the cha they
change their governing philosophies that
are over taxing people over regulating
people they're underperforming in
schools and safety and issues of public
importance and that's why it's happening
but no matter what state you call home I
will say this
2024 is going to be a critical year not
only for our country but for the world
as anyone who has lived in New York will
will tell you yeah elections have
consequences and in just 11 short months
and they will fly by you the American
people you will determine the future of
our country and frankly the trajectory
of the world now no one can predict the
outcome but I can tell you what the next
year will look like and by the way
anyone that does predict the outcome
they don't know what they're talking
about it's too unpredictable probably
the most unpredictable presidential
election year in our lifetimes now
Democrats the media mob they will work
in unison that I can predict with
certainty they will be on a NeverEnding
non-stop smear campaign regardless of
the Republican candidate they will
obsessively focus on Donald Trump Donald
Trump Donald Trump January 6 January 6
and of course abortion they don't want
to ever talk about Joe Biden's
accomplishments why because there really
aren't any they won't defend Biden's
radical agenda because it has resulted
in one National disaster after another
and you the American people you can see
it they don't want to talk about Biden
nomics because what 2third of our fellow
countrymen are living paycheck to
paycheck and the American people are
getting wrecked by Joe Biden's economy
of inflation High interest rates they
don't want to talk about Biden's
performance on the world stage why
because the president has been bullied
over and over and over again by our top
geopolitical foes as Joe has abdicated
America's role on the world stage the
world is paying a consequence we see
China openly planning an invasion or
what they call reunification it's an
invasion of our Ally Taiwan while
harassing our military in the Pacific
both in international Airways and
international waterways spying on our
nuclear sites right here in the
continental United States with a
slow-moving spy balloon that it turns
out they knew all about on top of all
the intellectual property theft all of
their unfair Trade Practices we now see
war in Europe as Russia invaded Ukraine
and War continues there and it seems
like there's no end in sight Biden has
utterly failed to deter what is one of
the bloodiest conflicts in recent
history and of course we have Iran the
number one state sponsor of Terror they
are enriching uranium at the fastest
Pace ever all while directing proxy wars
and other proxies to attack Americans
and our allies all over the region now
we have war in the Middle East on US
troops there have been 118 specific
attacks
including five in the New Year even the
houti rebels a radical group formed from
Yemen by the way funded by the Iranians
they're using fishing boats and rifles
to wreak havoc on important shipping
channels in the Red Sea all while Joe
Biden does little to nothing to respond
meanwhile our Southern border it is
worse than ever we have a lot more on
that coming up tonight and of course
crime is completely totally spiraling
out of several out of control of many
major American cities and even some
small towns and to put that special
cherry on top yeah tax collection is now
at an alltime high and with the extra
two plus trillion dollars Biden added to
the debt last year Well we started this
fiscal year in October with the national
debt now more than $34 trillion that is
a record and I don't know how we pay
that back so make no mistake Joe Biden
is your president has been and continues
to be an abject failure both at home and
abroad don't expect to see much of Joe
by the way in the leadup to November in
fact he will campaign probably less than
any other candidate in modern history if
Donald Trump or any Republican is the
candidate I even doubt he'll show up for
one debate he will lurk in the shadows
he will hide in the basement he will
hide on the beach in Del Delaware while
the media mob does all the heavy lifting
for him now it's not even clear that Joe
can do the lifting at all at this point
even the most basic conversation
are now really difficult for your
commanderin-chief and here's just the
latest and greatest take a look Mr
President before we start here about the
New Year I'm curious what sort of
holiday foods have you been enjoying
over the last few days well I've been
eating everything is put in front of me
I've eaten pasta which I love eating a
lot of chicken chicken parmesan I've
been eating all all Italian foods
basically and ice cream and ice cream
chocolate chip ice cream what's your
vide Revolution sir
anything else that's the biggest one
right now now Joe Biden's cognitive
ability is not good anyone with eyes to
see you can see it every week it gets
worse and and it's getting worse by the
day now keep in mind Biden is also
dealing with very real and serious
corruption and bribery allegations along
with a very real impeachment inquiry and
His Image as a loving father and
grandfather well that is forever been
shattered and tarnished by frankly his
disgusting treatment of his own
four-year-old granddaughter in Arkansas
in other words there are almost endless
reasons to dislike Joe Biden both
politically and personally and now
according to Galla Biden's year end
approval rating is now lower than any
other first-term president in modern
history going into a quote reelection
year he's even losing support among very
key demographics a big part of what is
the Democratic coalition
that which quote propelled him to
victory in 2020 look at this new USA
Today suffk University poll only 63% of
African-American voters support Joe
Biden why is that significant well
that's down from 87% that he was
receiving in 2020 and it only gets worse
from there Biden now Trails Trump among
Hispanic voters by five points after
easily winning winning a majority in
2020 and get this Biden is down four
points with another key constituency
among the Democratic base and that is
voters under 35 a usually very reliable
Democratic voting block if these numbers
hold Joe Biden if there's if he's their
candidate for re-election he will lose
today in a landslide but a lot can
happen between now and November let's be
very clear so let me start this year
with a warning to conservatives and to
Republicans if you want any chance of
winning in November you need to do a
couple of fundament Al basic things one
any conservative any Republican any
voter that has any reluctance or any
resistance to voting by mail and voting
early you have to get over that you just
can't start out these races on Election
night down by hundreds of thousands of
votes and depend on people voting day of
to make it up also many states that
allow legal ballot harvesting key word
legal and Republicans they need to start
matching the very very well organized
Democratic party efforts that would be
critical GOP organizers in every state
need to do it especially the swing
States they've got to adopt what is a
robust operation that is basically puts
them on a Level Playing Field and
working within the system not the one
you want it's not the system I want I
want day of voting of election day to be
a n a national holiday and I want paper
ballots that's not going to happen and I
want voter ID and I want partisan
observers watching the voting all day
and the vote counting all night in a
perfect world that would be what happens
but it's not the reality that is not our
current reality Republicans you have to
deal with the system the hand you're
dealt not the one you wish you had my
last piece of advice is on the
controversial issue of abortion not my
moral point of view but I'm looking at
it politically now first leave abortion
to the states that's what roie way did
and that I believe is more
constitutional if Republicans if you
want to push restrictive bans on
abortion like for example Doug mastriano
running for governor in Pennsylvania no
restrictions rap in CES mother's life he
lost by a margin of like 16 points that
had not been seen in Pennsylvania
history since the 1940s against a
non-incumbent uh opponent you'll pay a
heavy political price and by the way
you'll have no ability to even stop late
term abortions that many Democrats
support you can get The High Ground on
the issue look at Ohio that is a state
that Donald Trump won twice by a very
comfortable margin voters overwhelmingly
approved a measure to make abortion a
constitutional right in that red state
that ought to tell you a lot about the
issue of abortion GOP candidates you
need to be smart about this because in
11 months you have a prime opportunity
to regain power in DC and get our
country back on track before it's too
late hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to Subs subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else